good afternoon everyone
i'm pleased to be here to provide an
update on covet 19 in alberta
dr hinshaw is taking some much deserved
time off this week and so is unable to
attend today's update we'll but we'll be
back next week
today the numbers i'm sharing are from
tuesday march 22nd to monday march 28th
as always the detailed breakdown of data
is available at alberta.ca
let me begin by talking about two key
leading indicators that help us assess
the level of viral transmission in the
province positivity rates and waste
water surveillance
for march 22 to 28 our daily positivity
rate of pcr tests range from 21.7
to 27.1
with an average of 24.5 percent this is
a slight increase from the 22
average in the previous seven days
the wastewater surveillance data also
shows signs of rising transmission
a number of sites across the province
including edmonton and calgary are
showing initial signs of increasing
trends however as we know
wastewater data can be highly variable
so we will continue to monitor these
levels and other leading indicators in
the coming days and coming weeks
given that we have lifted the vast
majority of public health measures over
the last seven weeks it is not
unexpected that we are seeing a slight
increase in transmission of covet across
the province
there are simply more opportunities for
the virus to spread as more and more
people work from the office a return to
traveling socialize in various settings
and resume their regular routines
this is especially true as ba2 omicron
subvariant is a dominant strain in
alberta and is shown to be more
transmissible than ba1 our lab has found
that around 70 percent of all positive
pcr test samples are now ba ii
fortunately the available evidence does
not so far suggest that it causes more
severe illness than the previous omicron
strain
at this point we continue to have
capacity in the health system to address
the other surgical and medical needs of
albertans
since our update last week
hospitalizations have remained stable
there are currently six or sorry
964 people in hospital with coven 19
including 47 in the icu
sadly
lives are still being lost to this
disease over the last week 30 deaths
related to coven 19 have been reported
to alberta health
this averages just over four per day
my deepest sympathies go out to the
loved ones of these albertans my
sympathies are also with anyone who has
lost someone they care about no matter
the cause
even as we transition
our approach to managing covid we know
that the virus is still very much with
us it can still cause serious illness
complications and even death for some
albertans
that's why we continue to promote
vaccination
encourage individuals to make decisions
that best suit their unique situation
and risk tolerance
and invest in treatments like paxalopin
as you may recall paxlovit is the first
covenanting treatment approved by health
canada that can be taken orally at home
it was first approved for use in canada
in late january but due to limited
supply it was initially only available
at 135 pharmacies across the province
i'm pleased to report that as supply has
increased beginning this friday any
interested pharmacy in alberta will be
able to order paxlova treatments to
dispense paxloved to eligible albertans
who have met the clinical criteria
as a reminder
albertans who meet the eligibility
criteria which is available only by
prescription must call healthlink to
access the treatment
staff will ask screening questions to
confirm eligibility and arrange the next
steps for getting the most appropriate
covent 19 treatment
please do not call pharmacies or
physicians directly to get a
prescription as they will be unable to
give it to you
paxlovin must be started within five
days of symptoms so if you are if you
are eligible do not wait to see how
things develop
call healthlink as soon as possible
if you aren't sure if you are eligible
visit the ahs website to read the
criteria
while paxlova continues to be an option
to prevent mild or moderate cases of
covet 19 from regressing to severe
disease it is not a substitute for
vaccination
vaccination remains the most effective
way to prevent severe cases of covet 19
and reduce the risks that come with
getting infected so if you have not
received every dose available to you
please do so as soon as possible
if you have a child that still needs a
coven 19 vaccine dose try to take
advantage of the last day of extended
ahs clinic hours and walk-in
appointments tomorrow
a complete list of clinic locations and
hours is available
on the ahs website now if you can't make
it tomorrow don't worry
many pharmacies clinics and physician
offices across alberta can administer
the pediatric vaccines by appointment a
complete list again is available on the
blue cross website
finally i want all i want to encourage
all albertans to pick up rapid test kits
from their local pharmacy
as we're out and about and exposed to
more people it's a good idea to have
tests on hands if we develop symptoms
the kits are free and it's easier to get
now more than ever as you no longer need
to show your alberta healthcare card to
pick them up
once again i'd like to thank all of our
healthcare
providers our doctors our nurses those
working in hospitals and volunteers for
continuing to provide tremendous care
for all albertans through
the the last two years and through the
most recent omicron wave
thank you and now i'll take questions
thanks minister uh no one in the room
here with us uh but i think a couple of
reporters waiting on the phone so we'll
go to the first caller please
just track city news
hi there uh just wondering you know with
v8 ii is the dominant strain now and you
were just uh mentioning that we are
seeing sort of small increases in trends
that do you think we're going to enter a
sixth wave or have we already entered a
sixth wave
uh we're going to have to wait and see
you know if we look at
other jurisdictions
around the world and across the the
country we they you know we have seen
an increase in ba2 like an increase in
in cases
what remains to be seen is is how big
that wave how big that wave will be
and then what the impact will be on our
on our health care system um but you
know as indicated by um
dr tam and canada there's an expectation
is that we may see a rise in cases uh
but we're still gonna have to see what
that may it how that may impact our
health care center or our health care
system i i can say we there's you know
our wastewater data
is sort of the
one of the leading indicators we are
seeing a slight uptick initial uptick in
particularly in calgary and everton but
there's high variability in that so
we're going to have to watch and
over the next days and weeks to see
whether or not that is going to continue
to rise
thanks minister jeff follow follow-up
uh yeah a lot of people i know who
recently become sick say that it's kind
of hard to get their hands on a free
rapid testing kit i was responding what
what are supplies that are we are are we
still okay or are we running low on on
those kids
yeah i don't know the exact numbers uh
in front of me we can get that to you my
understanding is is that we have uh
significant supplies that are in
that we have distributed to uh to
pharmacies across the province but we'll
get you the the exact numbers i haven't
heard any concerns yet about supplies
and and but we'll we'll get you the
numbers and then we'll take a look at
the uh ensure that those numbers are
also updated on the website
yeah i will follow up separately jeff
thanks for that so uh we'll go to the
next caller please
stephanie thomas ctv
hi minister coughing well you did
mention that covet wastewater sampling
that's showing an increased presence of
the virus especially in calgary
so i'm wondering if perhaps your office
or dr henshaw's office has some other
data that you're looking at that might
link that rise in the case detection and
the wastewater to hospitalization is
that something you're seeing
yeah we're not we're actually seeing
hospitalizations um either being stable
or continue to trend downwards so we're
not seeing a link at this point in time
thanks follow-up stephanie
yeah so if it was to show that we are
headed to i suppose another wave with
severe outcomes including
hospitalizations what measures is your
office looking at implementing
well we're going to have to wait and see
first in terms of whether there is going
to be a uh be first of all is this going
is this are we at the start of another
wave one uh and the two what is the
impact on on hospitalized
hospitalizations um i do know and
again you look at other jurisdictions um
they
you know they have had uh an increase in
ba2 which you know indicated there was a
slight bump in uh in
cases in the community um and also a
small bump in hospitalization so there
wasn't a need to actually take any
measures at that point in time uh so
we're gonna quite frankly we're gonna
have to wait and see we'll watch there's
some other jurisdictions that are ahead
of us on this i will watch what they are
doing and then we'll see
you know our own indicators of what
actions we may or may not have to take
but but again it goes back to um what is
the severity going to be i you know i am
comforted to some regard some regards um
from a in a couple of from a couple of
points first
we we have relatively high levels of
vaccination uh you know for those who
are 12 plus you know over 90 percent
with uh uh with at least one dose and
and second doses and third doses are
continuing to uh to go up uh there is
some population protection from a
previous infection uh from va uh ba1 and
we have access broader access to uh
treatment sites such as paxlovit so
again we're watching very carefully uh
the numbers and we're looking at other
jurisdictions to assess the risk
thanks minister we'll go to the next
caller
elena smith canadian press
hi mr copping i'm hoping to provide an
update for us based on alberta's
strategy for the rollout of fourth doses
yeah i think
dr hinshaw spoke about fourth doses last
week or at this point in time
for only the
the
you know potentially for the
immunocompromised and not going anything
further we will rely on the
the expert advice from
the national uh committee
on immunization as well as our our
alberta committee as well
follow up elena
sure yeah i'm also just wondering um are
you getting any reports of folks getting
fourth doses who aren't yet eligible and
are those numbers of who's gotten fourth
doses available online
so i have to double check we we are
tracking those who are actually getting
uh fourth doses um and uh so we actually
have those exact numbers so we can get
them to to you i my recollection is that
um given that we don't have a total
population of what is quote unquote
amino compromise we may not have a good
percentage
of that or it may not be as accurate but
we can get you the exact numbers of four
doses
thanks for that minister uh we'll take
one more caller
so we'll go ahead with the last caller
calgary herald
i think my question um i'm just
wondering if doctor henshaw wasn't
available for
questions today why wouldn't the
province's wdc's medical officer of
health made available to answer
questions
well quite frankly we didn't we didn't
feel it was uh necessary for today dr
hinshaw will be back uh next week and if
there are any uh detailed questions that
we need to provide answers to
we can get them through our
steve
and through the cmoh's office and they
can provide it
thanks minister brittany follow-up
thank you i'm just going to transmission
increasing uh what advice does the
project have
right now for people as they're uh
planning their upcoming daughters
so so again
um you know we are moving to a system of
of individuals living with covet
so our first set of advices is you know
we we ask you know albertans to assess
their own risk right uh understand you
know um
what their level of comfort is uh and
then be guiding accordedly accordingly
as well as you know
go get rapid tests as indicated earlier
today if you haven't uh
gotten all your
booster shots that you're eligible for
please do so
and then and then continue to um listen
for updates um from you know our offices
as we go forward but but again you know
as we move into a position where we're
learning to live with covid you know
asking individuals to
manage their own risk
and be able to take actions
accordingly
thanks very much minister and thanks for
reporters who called in we'll wrap up
there and see you next week thanks very
much
you